we started playing with
being able to make different
loop-de-loops
so that we can start more interestingly
playing with
geometry as we're spinning poi instead
of just making circles
your hands kind of still on a circle
making a weave
we can start playing with making
loop-de-loops
which can turn into flower patterns or
linear patterns or all sorts of patterns
and i'll need a partner anybody want to
demonstrate
he's my human boy like this
and i'm going to spin him around and i'm
not i'm not trying to like throw him
into a wall or anything here
so i'm just leading him around as though
he's the piece
so let's say i want him i want to bring
him over to the right there
there's two ways i can do that when i'm
facing away from the right
i can pull him with me like so
and that accelerates him and draws him
out into an arc most people are familiar
with an extension or a sort of expanding
move
the other move that is similar to a loop
is that when i'm pointing it that way
and i'm looking the way i want to go if
i just
move that way i'll effortlessly
overtake him he sort of does this little
loop-de-loop footwork out of the way
and then i pull him along so we did that
to really get the feel for
how loops and arcs work so with poi
the same sort of idea is that i'm going
to move my hand
across to here if i do so when the koi
is the farthest away i'm going to
stretch it over
in an arc and that accelerates what's
going on with the poi
on the other hand if i move right when
the poi is here
kind of pointing in the direction that
i'm going to move my hand
all of its momentum really just wants to
go down and so when i move my hand
it just sort of makes this little loopty
loop down and i lose
tension it's sort of like this relaxing
of what the poi is doing
so my hand effortlessly moves over the
top and then i feel a little tug
as i pull out of the loop you can do the
same thing as the poi is swinging up
pointing that way i move my hand
underneath it and it makes a loop
and we can do that top to bottom bottom
to top
and just practice these different ways
that we can make loops
and when you get comfortable with that
movement this loop is sort of the basic
building block or a brush stroke you've
gotten comfortable with
that you can use to paint your flower
patterns
or even just linear movements
and of course once you've gotten
comfortable those with both of your
hands
you can start playing with that idea in
different ways with both hands
that will eventually turn into different
types of flower patterns
here's an interesting one that i've been
doing that involve loops but i'm snaking
them around my body
so if i'm high and low we know that if i
move from low to high or high to low i
make little horizontal loopy loops
if i do that around my body it makes
this interesting
tracing pattern around my body but if
it's still making loops right around my
shoulders
then i can start
turning that making different loops in
different places which is pretty fun
we also applied the idea of making arcs
and loops to
learn how to do a triquetra anti-spin
pattern easy
it's a three petal anti-spin pattern it
looks like this
and we we learned one where the the
triangular
shape of the triquetra has a tip a loop
pointing up
but you can do them all over the place
you can point them sideways or down
the easy way to learn that is to make
make your legs like a triangle
and start sort of down here at the base
of the triangle as your poi is swinging
up past your arm
move it up to make a loop at the top of
the triangle and then down to the other
leg
when you get there as your poi is
swinging around towards you
drag an arc back to the other foot
when you put that together without extra
rotations you get a loop
and an arc and a loop and an arc points
up
points up points up points up
and you're actually getting the the two
loops
at your feet for free basically when you
think of it this way
so eventually you'll actually realize oh
i've got a loop there there
there there up foot foot up foot
foot i'm getting loops there and i'm
also getting i'm getting an
arc there there there there there there
there so there's actually three loops
and three arcs but all you have to do is
focus on
one loop and one arc at first to make it
easy to learn
from there instead of making a really
angular triangle
you can take that feeling and sort of
just start smoothing it out until it's a
nice arm circle
and you can play with it either way make
it a smooth circle make it an angular
feeling triangle whatever you want to do
i talked a little bit about spinning in
a hallway
that when you're spinning your coin
parallel planes you essentially have
a wall on either side of your body
framing you
so if i'm in a hallway
my poi are the hallway
i can look you know north up the hallway
i can turn and look west at a hallway
wall
i can look south down the hallway
where i could look east at the other
hallway wall
right now my one boy is drawing a circle
on one hallway wall
and on one on the other hallway wall
and if i if i make just a quarter turn
i'm going to end up
in wall plane just drawing circles on
one wall where i can
do some different things but make
another quarter turn
and facing the other way down the
hallway where i can do
other sorts of movements
where i'm circling on both walls of the
hallway
if i make another quarter turn once
again i'm in the other wall plane
and one more quarter turn gets me back
to where i was basically on the hallway
we really want to learn how to do that
just circling our arms
because our koi don't have joints in
them
our boy can spin around however you want
them to but our arms have a range of
motion where
sooner or later your shoulder can't bend
that way anymore so we played around
with
split time same direction like swimming
in the hallway
my feet are pointing forward no matter
how twisted up i get
my feet are the most honest thing about
which way my body are facing so
i'm facing forward but my my torso is
twisting
in order to complete these circles
because my torso is twisting it can't be
um
i can get overzealous about that focus
and start twisting
too much and throw my spinning off so
like from the front right
i could be i could be swimming like this
but
i could also start to kind of spin too
much and my planes will get funny
and if i have poi in my hands doing that
the koi are going to wobble way off the
plane
i want two two volunteers
with some partners here let's put a left
back right forward
we can all circle our arms
so being able to do this with with some
partners
or maybe like a tree or a post something
like that that you can put in front or
behind you
you'll test to see whether you're
actually keeping your plane straight
or if they're wobbling too much and sort
of brushing up against your partner
so that's a very good practice
you